hey what's up this Killer Mike AKA
Michael render check me out on the
bootleg care podcast hey you're about to
watch the new interview brought to you
by Blue Chu get a month supply of blue
Chu for free fellas that's right
blue.com promo code bootleg right now
get a month supply for free helping you
with that erectile dysfunction with the
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Calis but you don't got to go to the
doctor it's all online and it's
delivered right to your front door
that's how we doing things let's get
into the interview
bleake C podcast man special guest in
here Mr Alum of the Year yep Grammy
nominated again right yep three times
Grammy nominated one time last time you
got [__] you got uh what I'd like to
call
snubbed run the Jews run the Jews got
snubbed that's what they say I just was
man I remember being brokenhearted but
you were but you were right yeah R2 j4
should have been nominated I think so
yeah I think so yeah uh well listen it's
all good though because Michael is
nominated Killer Mike is here yep
welcome what's up you do have the album
of the year I have my list you're number
one my number two album is not even a
rap album but I'm going to do my hip-hop
list but you're number one by far man
thank you I said that to you too in the
studio mean I said I know a lot of
people just be saying crazy [__] cuz
they've seen it work for other people
over the years but having had put the
work in I wouldn't I wouldn't have
bullshitted you so no for sure now yeah
you played me a version of the album
about two years ago uh in Atlanta and uh
some of the stuff made it some of the
stuff is didn't make it but you've
definitely for people who don't know
like uh and haven't heard you speak
about the album you describe it as kind
of like your uh Wolverine origin story
yeah yeah Ronald jwes is very much the
X-Men it's like the UNC County X-Men any
number of characters will pop up and in
and out and um you know depending on who
your favorite character was you knew
their Origins where they came from and
stuff Wolverine had always been one of
mine Logan I love Magneto is the reason
part of the reason I name my company
villains let me m yeah Magneto is part
of the reason I even call my company
villains because I believe villains
aren't necessarily bad guys you know
what I mean they just have a different
agenda in terms of solving the big
problem but all that to say run the
jewels man rest in peace to Lola you
know what I'm saying gangster Buu Zack
de laoka Josh hom M Staples two chains
big boy all these people have been a
part of the run the Jews universe and um
I realized that my character Killer Mike
this bad swaggering dope ass MC that
essentially his 9-year-old kid named
Michael created and built out of his
imagination the story of Michael had
never gotten told I never people didn't
know where killer mighte came from or
why you know people interpreted
confidence and arrogance and [__] like
that but you know when you grow up in in
the middle of hip-hop hip-hop's you know
been around 50 years but it's been
giving a lot of a lot of kids a lot of
little boys you know a reason to hold
their chin up Swagger so you know I had
to realize that I had to introduce
myself to people that's yeah I mean cuz
it this is your first solo album since
rap music yes 11 years yeah that's crazy
and for people who don't know rap music
is what really what kicked off run the
jewels yep yep y it's the pre-run the
jewels yeah yeah um and and it's crazy
to think like I feel like 11 years ago
was three years ago yeah it does it
feels three years ago yeah it does but
it's crazy like we've had a a pretty
crazy historical run that you've been a
part of with LP and like you know I know
you took your time with this project and
I'm just I'm just glad man that like the
Grammys got got it right I feel like a
couple of years ago like you know there
was a couple of Grammy nominations that
I I was glad to see Royce got nominated
and Freddy Gibbs got nominated and when
they nominated you a couple of times
this year I was like thank God cuz well
three times yep yep two four um rap song
of the year rap performance of the year
in sciences and then at rap album of the
year and that's what that's what I you
know um I ain't going to lie I want it
you I I I want rap album of the year cuz
I'm proud to be a rapper yeah you know
I'm damn proud to be a rapper a lot of
people you know they um they get rap
album the year and they act like that's
a snub you know what I'm saying people
have acted as though in the past well I
deserve the album of the year Well I
personally feel like yeah I gave you the
album of the year in terms of depth of
human
emotion vulnerability Stell I gave you
what music is supposed to give you
whether it's the blues or rock and roll
or Soul or Funk or rap I gave that to
you but I care and covet rap of the rap
album of the year because for the last
50 years this has been a driving you
know cultural force in this in this
country you know rap wasn't even my
music first it was my mom's music my mom
was only 16 when she had me so the First
music I'm hearing from her is Disco and
early rap records you know so it matters
to me because of what rockim gave to me
Eric being and rockim because of what
rund DMC gave to me because what Outcast
and Goody Mob gave to me because of what
Nas's first two LPS especially gave to
me you know when you start talking about
Far Side what they gave to me D
hieroglyphics they gave to me I win that
award I'm going to be the proudest
person to have ever held that award you
know because I give a damn about being a
rapper and an MC this is not a secondary
job this ain't some [__] I did cuz I
couldn't play sports this is not that's
no like to anyone I was just too chubby
to play sports what's your frame of
reference Mike some of my best friends
won an NCA Championship UCLA one of my
other best friends got got got drafted
to the Buffalo Bills my friends Dolphins
so I knew yeah I ain't gonna be no
athlete I'm G be I'm G be the best
goddamn rapper out of my friend group so
I care and and I think that um a lot of
mcing is based on these that is kind of
acting as though you don't care but I
care I want it I also think like you
have one of the more unique paths to a
Grammy nomination if you just look at
the way your career played out like
obviously coming out with Outcast and
the whole world is where a lot of people
were introduced to you uh obviously you
know your first album was incredible and
I feel like your first album isn't on
Spotify or Monster I don't know I don't
even I don't think monsters I still ride
old school so how do I listen to Monster
cuz I'm pretty sure it's not on your
Spotify account I still ride CDs I still
ride old school so um but no but it's
crazy and then you have your gr your
Grind Time rap rap [__] where you're
dropping mixtapes and you're dropping
records like like you you you you really
on your [__] I mean I first heard pill
through you and a bunch of a bunch of
young artist out of Atlanta I I
discovered through those projects and
then rap music is one of the best rap
albums ever in my opinion than so much
and it kicks off this whole Unexpected
Journey of run the jewels last decade me
and LP
and you know in a in a world in which
rap groups Duos Etc don't exist anymore
yeah you guys have thrived in a way that
like really it's like y'all in the Migos
yeah shouts out to the Migos rest in
peace of take off um shouts out to qu
and for you to take all this time to
kind of reintroduce the world to Michael
yeah and get the acknowledgement get the
nod man it's just a beautiful thing to
see so man I appreciate you I appre I
want it so you know y'all y'all send me
some prayer some good energy and hope we
move them people hearts on there you
know vote for vote for the person who
first of all again has put put together
the rap album of the year and beyond
that I really I really give a damn about
it yeah and like uh I always so so like
obviously when I first heard the album I
always wonder a couple of things cuz you
and your lady are amazing you guys are
you know obviously you uh she's she's
been talked about by you a lot I've met
your wife a lot she's cool as hell Shay
biger when did you give Shay a heads up
about the summer record like hey I'm
going to write I'm going to write this
song about this exf fling from back in
the day no that was my f was my
girlfriend my yeah I don't hey guys ball
up now don't just be be a real [__]
about [__] you know what I mean and you
just your wife was in love with somebody
before she met you even if she was eight
and youin one of count it's very rare
that that actually is the case hey man
your grandparents say they was but my my
you know yeah I canot know my Grandad my
Grandmama was a virgin I can't tell you
my grandfather was you know just saying
so you know I um such a dope
storytelling record though yeah she had
already heard the story cuz we talked
that's my friend course you know so I I
I think that that um it wasn't a need to
to um say hey I'm going to rap about I
think I think she was just like you
finally got a chance to get it off your
chest yeah cuz it's something that's
that I've been with and it's been with
me and it's sat with me and when I
played the record from Men And for those
who might not know what he's talking
about that you shouldn't be out there
but you know give Slumber a listen it's
a story of me at 1516 fall in love with
a girl who's a year two younger than me
and us living like adults essentially
for two summers I'm you know I'm
thinking I'm trapping on Rich you know
she in the apartment so subsidized so
Ain like we got many bills but we live
like adults and we we and we get
pregnant and I have to go through the ab
the abortion process you know with her
paying for it and um man I played it for
dudes and dudes wept and they say man
nobody had ever expressed how I felt you
know I hadn't even been considered that
I had feelings and we knew it was
traumatic for the girl for the woman
absolutely it is and they deserve all
the empathy and all the support around
controlling their bodies they deserve
but man them little boys and them men
and these young men that have had to
take part in that there is nobody
sometimes to put the arm around the
shoulders so I know that was a difficult
decision to make and I know it's going
it's going to stay with you or let me
tell you it's going to stay with you you
know you're going to feel away about it
you know so I was honored to be able to
do it and my and my my my wife is glad I
got out my chest you know now she like
now you can stop talking now you
sh the world knows the story now yeah
uh for you man you have a lot of
vulnerable moments on this album
obviously uh motherless to me is like
one that really um really stands out I
know I want to say when you played the
album for people who don't know you had
like a really cool album listening thing
here in La that was at like a masonic
temple or it was it was it was at a
cemetery it was at a cemetery a masonic
it was a cemetery but I remember just
walking like
Illuminati like yo you joined the
Illuminati that's why you got the
gravity yeah
exactly hanging out with
Freemon um but no I know you got really
emotional talking about that the record
cuz it's about your mom you know what
I'm saying yeah my girl man Denise she
she under here her and my grandmother my
mother was 16 years old when she she had
me and um you know we just grew up
together that was my girl you know like
that's the first person that introduced
me to rap music that's she was I mean
being 16 she's also kind of your friendo
yeah she was like my big sister you know
what I'm saying that's who taught me how
to dance with a girl right you know what
I'm saying that's who taught me how to
how to approach a girl you like that's
who that's who taught me how to take no
[__] you know don't be no sucker and she
wasn't no single mom you know my I had
two dads you know my dad who's
biologically my dad and my dad she
married I had grandparents that raised
me grew up in a you know a man and woman
household raising me and my two little
sisters but me and my mom just shared
this special bond and friendship and kop
and it was around you know her saying
you know I wish I could be softer you
about some stuff but you're the only boy
I got so you got to be a man but at her
heart she was an artist so she she
encouraged that about me you know what I
mean so I just man I just I want to I
want to lead a life that makes her proud
essenti for you um looking at the
nominees of rap album of the year yeah
the motherless record I'm sorry that
record just to say I got emotional about
that record cuz cuz I miss her so
anybody out there who has a mother no
matter your relationship check in on CU
I think we take advantage of those
things my mom my mom told me she said
you know I I know you think your
grandmother is your mama cuz she she
raised you but I'm your [__] mama
that's that's kind of conversation you
have and she said and when I go when I
go you going to understand it and the
day she died I've never felt that
emptiness and and I know it doesn't get
filled and a lot of people don't realize
that until that day happened it's
happened yeah I didn't [__] she told me
yeah you know I I you know I I I I you
know I tithe and and make my offerings I
I I you know I I got a
I got a place in my house where I honor
but with that said like man I wish I
could have said it while she was here I
get it it's such a beautiful song it
really I mean that's a record that I
feel like could have been nominated for
a Grammy it could have been it could
have been should have been would have
been will be one day who knows you know
remixed album or something but I just
know I got the to cover it all album of
the Year 100% and an album to live to
yeah I was going to say who do you see
as uh if you're looking at the other
nominees for rap album of the year yeah
I got my opinion but who do you think is
the album you got to worry about I don't
know I I just know that I've listened to
them all and I I like parts of all of
them you know and I respect the artist
involved but what I'm saying is as as I
could sit down Drake and Savage I could
sit down Nas I could sit down Travis
Metro booming and I could sit down with
Metro I said Metro last cuz he's the
producer he put together Mars I could
put those artists in a room and I could
play my album and something about my
experience in my life is going to affect
all of them out that alum in a deeply
personal way and I you know what I mean
like you know in a deeply personal way
and and I don't say that to be in
competition with but just saying I made
an album that we all can bleed to I made
an album that we all understand
addiction we all understand the precious
preciousness of a mother we all are
black men in North America trying to
understand and make our way I don't care
what color um Drake is in terms of how
people argue about his bir raciality and
[__] since he's been Coming to America
he knows he's a black man if he been in
Atlanta he knows he's a black man if he
been in Houston or Memphis so there's
something on here for the worker class
the black men and the women who love
them for all of us so I believe that if
we sat down at a table I could have that
argument with those men and say this is
why like amongst the fraternity and
Brotherhood of MC's at their table this
is why this is why I should and listen
to this and it'll pierce your heart the
same way it's piercing the audience's
heart for sure man I think it was a an
like almost like a much needed Medicine
of of Hip Hop it's like somebody
actually is making a a vulnerable album
to like live to not to turn up to not to
tick Tok to it's just well I mean you
can still do it all I mean the intro of
down by law made a Tik Tok I was like
God damn I'm going have to get in shape
everybody gym [__] was you know the
journey Rico was talking and and and
with that said exit 9 you cruise to this
a record you play and 56 minutes later
after you drive from Hit or Pomona man
you've like I've just had experience I
feel like I saw a movie this is this is
an album where when you clean up your
house by the time the album end you done
finish that chore man your laundry done
and folded it is a it is a classic album
in that it feels good even the sad parts
even the parts that make you think about
a reminisent stuff that but it makes you
feel good you feel more human after it
so you know I'm I'm just glad to be the
conduent for that energy because hip hop
deserved that in his 50th year in the
50th year for sure in the 50th year yeah
for sure when people are talking about
what's sales are down and yaad yaad Y I
didn't I didn't know [__] about sales
when I first heard hip hop I just knew I
felt something when I heard it it made
me feel something and and that's what I
did I'm curious
um I first heard of a new Andre 3000
album when you spilled some beans that
you weren't supposed to spill Stone man
D bro Stone but when you when you
revealed that and then kind of walked it
back at that moment in time did you know
it was a FL a flute album I have no
comment on any of this I know if you
want an Andre 3000 verse there's an
album called Michael and it's on there
song called scientists and engineers and
you should listen to it have you um have
you gotten high to the to the Andre
album because it's a great album to
relax to got high to it got Stone well
I'm stoned period I'm stoned if I'm
listening to Metallica I'm stoned but I
um I was curious to hear it like
everybody else and and and I play and I
smoke and I'm going to probably eat some
shrooms it's good shrooming music
I'm proud of um I'm proud of Dr and big
boy because they are out of a talent
program uh called Tri Cities high school
that also produced Escape that also
produced um KP one of the greatest ever
come y shouts out to KP KP the great DJ
as well it it just produced some amazing
artists and those guys like I tell you
about keeping that inner child alive big
boys kept it pushing and going giving us
new Styles variants whether it's fagr or
whatever whatever um
new ination me he helped us he's
introduced so many artists to us so many
man I love them and and with Dre Dre
just being an artist in that waiting
until he's ready to make art to make art
and get people interested um beyond what
they thought they were interested in I
think is amazing so I'm I'm very proud
of him I'm very proud of big you know
cut Master Swift their DJ did all the
cuts on Michael he's coming back in with
us we do make more music cuz he's an
amazing Trumpeter sing so we you know
the dungeon family lives Pat Ray and
reek still doing beats like I mean I got
a beat I'm riding around right now so
for me man I'm just I'm proud that that
for whatever whatever compels you he's
being compelled to do
something yeah it's crazy because I just
had uh Victoria uh um Janelle Monet I
was gonna say Victoria mon Janelle Monet
um on the show and we're talking we were
talking about her uh her purple ribbon
run yeah cuz like a I don't think a lot
of people like kind of give the proper
respect to that like that roster of
artists big boy isn't big boy is an
amazing he's an amazing guy in terms of
picking talent and doing business
sometimes you're just a little ahead of
the curve yeah all stars are so good and
it was like so many names you're on
there like oh [__] oh [__] rest in rest
in peace to Nate super Nate died of
cancer last year rest in peace to him
shouts out to Black on SE on little bro
you know shouts out to sleepy brown know
shouts out to sh out Bubba mhm yeah for
sure man um for you man um talk to me
about like you know I know uh the focus
is Michael Y how
many times have you been in with LP in
the last like 12 months working on music
if if
any man we've been together cuz we were
touring we haven't worked on any music
working on music you guys had the Tour
by the way I'm still very mad that the
rage tour never happened for me to see
with my own eyes man I I wish you would
F York K and and I'm glad Zack is healed
up back on the minut and congrats to all
the guys they got int introducted in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame rightfully so
yeah the way Runner Jews usually work is
L tra off into the whe you know he TS
off into the Wilderness somewhere and
probably like kills bears and eats them
and lives as a wild man and then comes
back with a plethora of be I feel like
you'd be the guy that kill bears and eat
them n I'm I'm definitely down to kill
[__] and eat it usually we prefer
killing deer and hog where I'm from but
just went hog hunting with that Mexican
OT we you had fun down Texas you had we
had a ball right it was so much fun who
dressed who dressed them for you they
already had someone on site to dress the
hall cooking make sausages all that for
you we not cooking we just killed him
and left them no that's what we did no
you're not supposed to do that I swear
to God this out in Texas they're like
pest I don't know no but you're you're
supposed to [__] eat them it's a hog
you're not supposed to so we so we
killed a couple of them and then we came
back and like a pack of coyotes or
something destroyed them yeah that's
good yeah I'm just saying you're not so
you know I know they're like get so
feral out there but you kill I kill
something I'm going eat it like I'm
sorry I'm not sports fishing I'm not
putting a [__] bass bag that bass
call the B getting Ed that's my
grandfather say I'm eding it you know so
yeah no I mean I kind of felt I mean
because I've never been that's the only
time I ever been hunting good though you
should do that it was fun everyone
should do it at least you know at least
gets out once a year do something we
also were doing it out of a helicopter
yeah I've seen it I've seen it um Kor
shouts out to kinor who I interview
years he um he he he go I saw him I've
seen him go out and lean out the
helicopter a video of himing I was
[__] spooked that [__] was dope yeah
hey we we're going on a hunting tangent
uh back to you and LP so LP he goes out
and he kills bears and does whatever he
yeah and he comes back with a plethora
of Beats on a hard drive like like what
do you think and and what what I think
is usually oh [__] this is the [__]
album and like sequence and everything
damn near like oh my God this is it and
then from there it's right writing and
then we just in there we're just in
there was vibing more than writing we
just start playing [__] like he came out
here we were out here I forgot when it
was it might have been a year or might
have been just over but he came out we
were in different hotels but he came
over um to a spot I was at and he just
played something for me and he had part
of reverse on I said oh let me let me
let me get in there and um I went in
there man I spazzed on that [__] like
I'm like oh [__] so you know to me I'm
just like I want to finish that one and
whenever we finish that one if he come
with we might get rtj 5 I mean it's it's
got to happen one day that's something I
cheer for but again we're just you know
it's it's when it's going to happen like
when it happens but until it happens if
you're looking for a Dre verse Michael
or if you're looking for one half I got
LP verse I got both of them on Michel
and it's like and even the record with
LP on the album is like different for
y'all we got good dope on the street
that's all I'm telling you man we still
here for you man you want to hear run
the jewels you need to listen to don't
let the devil it's a it's a no ID beat
with a LP Chop on it different LP
chopped it so yeah and Taco Taco was on
the drums on there right yep little
Shalamar who's who's one of the run the
Jews co-producers he was on there so
yeah man so I got the dope you do man
come get the dope man come run it up hey
what up y'all you already know my bookie
man we just made so much money this past
weekend if you did not get in on that
crazy deal that we had it's all good man
you can still get down with that free
deposit bonus up to $200 all right right
now if you go to mybookie.ag we're
gambling on NBA we're gambling on
football I've been murdered m in the NFL
murdering it I do these four team super
teasers you get plus 13 on NFL games
listen if you can't hit a plus 13 teaser
I don't know what to tell you but I will
tell you this when you go to mybookie.ag
you sign up with a new account you're
going to get that first deposit bonus
using the promo code bootleg you got to
use that promo code bootleg mybookie.ag
promo code bootleg they're going to give
you free money to gamble with that's
right it's so easy what are we talking
about man I man I've been running it up
on my bogie for almost 10 years you know
what I'm saying they reached out to me
and they were like we'd love to sponsor
your podcast I say check my account ID
buddy you already been taking a lot of
my money it's time we get some of that
back but I've been on a roll with my
bookie man so go to mybookie.ag they got
the casino live Blackjack roulette
whatever you're into craps they got the
uh slots but most importantly we talking
about this sports book you could also
cash out early now what let's say you
hit three out of four of the legs on
your parlay cash that [__] out take
your money and go go back to your bed
and go to sleep you know what I'm saying
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg get that
deposit bonus right now wherever you're
at we all good with my bookie also want
to give a shout out to our folks at
Imperial right now salute to Imperial
extractions if y'all don't know Imperial
extractions they're OG's in this man
they got 16 years of uh experience when
it comes to this West Coast cannabis
scene right Imperial
extraction look this what they
do Straight premium luxury products if
you're a smoker if you're a toker toker
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into they got it and right now we all
love free weed I know I love free weed
who doesn't love free weed you can get a
free 2 G
thca Diamond infused pre-roll premium
cannabis
uh in it of course if y'all ain't heard
16 years experience uh and now Imperial
extraction they're throwing their hat
into the hemp game that means that this
can get delivered to you wherever you
are wherever you're at legally it's
getting delivered to your door la king
Kush cereal milk we got flavors for days
we got flavors for days white Berry runs
come on man this is the most important
thing go to Imperial extraction. comom
use the promo code bootleg right now
they're going to send you one of these
straight to your door for free with your
order who doesn't love free weed we're
talking about a two G premium luxury
pre-roll look at these glass tips come
on man this ain't that [__] this
that real [__] right here you bust one
of these bad boys open and there
diamonds in here bro you know what I'm
saying I'm just letting you know all
right if you want some free weed
Imperial extraction. comom Imperial
extraction. promo code bootleg get you a
free pre-roll sent to your crib right
the [__] now now let's get back to the
interview um yo have do you see my
tweets like once every two months I
tweet that you should run for
president probably have you seen these
tweets I swear every two months I'm
tweeting will Killer Mike just run for
president I don't want them people to
kill me I want to rap I want to build
some bus would you ever like like I know
you've asked been asked if you'd ever R
for office but like I could see somebody
getting elected eventually and making
you a part of their
cabinet you know what I remember
remember when I think one of the bushes
put Arnold Schwarzenegger on their
cabinet over physical fitness and that's
one thing I've seen in my life I've seen
that made all the sense in the world
yeah because you see Arnold and you're
like yeah I'm like putting a brain
surgeon who I have an enormous amount of
respect for over housing Urban
Development was a little quirky for me
but Dr Ben Carson grew up in the housing
projects right I would have liked to
have seen Dr Ben Carson while he was
over the housing projects Institute some
type of mandate that that gave kids
options and benefits for learning who's
doing that now Buddha Buddha Pete is it
Pete no I thought Pete was doing
Transportation or something I could be
wrong could be over but but I always
thought that that was an opportunity
Miss because I thought that if Ben could
have figured something out between
between Health hood and um education
that we could have been educating kids
right in the housing projects
differently so if I did something in the
cabinet that made sense I'd be honored
to but I doubt so you so you'd be open
to that I'd be I'd be open to that
because I could I could do something
effective and I wouldn't have to
prostitute myself for money because the
person that hired me would have already
done that like had the DNC not like
[__] over Bernie Sanders I feel like
you'd be you would definitely you would
definitely would have been in the
cabinet yeah I was really believer you
know and whatever the old guy was even
if I wouldn't have been in the cabinet I
would have helped I would have helped in
any way and you guys are it's crazy
because like you are such a leader and I
feel like you know when I think of like
um the word activist that as a where
that gets thrown around um and I think
about like how you and Bernie show up to
like the Amazon Stripes yeah down in
Alabama yeah you know what I'm saying
like um that's something that like
you're working on albums you're touring
but like somehow you still find the time
you still find the energy to like still
stand up and and and just be the voice
of the voice well you know what don't
man it's not just me you know and and I
consider myself a product of the worker
class in this country I am you know both
my dads my grandpa my my grandma you
know Working Class People hardworking
decent people fed Integrity good morals
and they just wanted better if they made
mistakes they learned from those
mistakes and push forward so you know
for me I'm not the only one you know
when you when you look at Senator Nina
Turner I feel like she should be the
leader of the Progressive Movement in
this country you know I I think I think
that for us to talk about and I'm
talking about my community I'm the black
community for us to talk about
progression and not be talking about her
actively is damn near crime like what's
wrong with us it's like ignoring Malcolm
in the' 60s which people did they did
you know the people ignored Malcolm in
after he was dead all of a sudden he had
more fandom and because of people like
Dick Gregory you know when people say
celebrities don't mean much because of
people like dick Gregory's name stayed
Al alive people like Spike Lee his name
stayed alive so for me you know my thing
is teslin figuro who now pops up on The
Breakfast Club you know has her has her
has her own um podcast and is also does
work with Revolt teslin is an amazing
political mind and part of the reason I
stay you know um just in know of what is
is cuz I constantly communicate with
people like Nina I constantly
communicate with nah with teslin you
know Jennifer Farmer is amazing
publicist out of the Bary campaign
system black woman out Ohio in but just
brilliant when it comes you know so my
thing is stay in touch with the people
doing the work and less of an organizer
now because my my day job takes me away
but more of a mobilizer how do you get
people there by the time Dr King was
maybe two three years before he got out
of you know here and was assassinated by
this part this government is my belief
um Dr King was was a mobilizer when he
show up they knew people were going to
show up but people organizing on the
ground included people like John Lewis
included people like Reverend James
orange included people like stokeley
carmichel you know you know also known
as quame T that's who we need we need
more of y'all right you know I I'd love
for another Killer Mike to pop along you
know what I mean but until that happens
you got to congratulate the people that
are working their ass off to try the
best they you know try to be the best
they can be and I think that they are
worthy of our support locally but look
hyper local I want to tell people that
don't be so enamored by what the
television is telling you to argue about
be involved with the the counil theal
hyper before you even get to your
counsilman what do your 10 neighbors
think of the street see I I learned this
first from my grandmother my grandmother
didn't like the way sanitation was
leaving people garbage cans or something
on the stre she she didn't think enough
care concern right and so she took it to
city council she was angry about it and
she would didn't get satisfied what she
heard so she went and sat in the mayor's
office till he saw her she literally
just went and sat in here until until
she complain and she still didn't get
what she wanted and within two weeks we
were on Channel 5 News was my
grandmother saying this is how they do
the black folks black community all of a
sudden we've never had issues with
sanitation again cuz that black mayor it
wants to get elected that black city
council person and they say they want to
do good for the black community well put
our barbish cans down respectfully cuz
we respectful people we clean our yard
and and it just she was my hero in that
fashion and I Want More Heroes like that
because that's the way you create a
killer you create a fanny ler you you
you know you you create you create all
these people that care that Aid the
people that may be the tip of the spear
you know Bayard Russ you you create
these people by being hyperactive so
whoever on a local level in your town is
doing something take some time to help
them out I was going to say like it it
feels that what would be your message
for people who are so just exhausted
with the process because it feels like a
a
hopeless political landscape nationally
World worldly things are like obviously
we got we got Wars going on in the world
I said listen to what I just told you
yeah yeah what I tell just focus on what
you cuz what you can really control is
your neighbors is you could you know
stuff you if you all do a little nobody
got to do a lot if all you all you do a
little bit 100% follow us do a little
bit um I'm wondering man for you uh have
you thought about uh my boy jelly roll
just had a speech that Viral out Jelly
man oh thank you he was jelly was one of
the first DMs I looked at when um I got
nominated and um it just I've been
cheering for him all year yeah i' been I
literally been cheering for it's crazy
cuz people don't realize he kind of
comes from that like underground white
boy rap World well you know I'm a
southerner so you know little white
jelly roll all that all yeah you don't
it's not yellow wolf my brother like
yeah you don't you don't miss it cuz we
all from the same place might have been
a tra
it is it's like so I was cheering for
him and we we share a lot of
similarities you know what I'm saying we
you guys each have very unique paths to
where you currently are yeah when I
heard his Grammy speech my sister my
sister sent it to me cuz she loves them
to death and she said she say he said
she said sounds like somebody I know get
your speech ready F yeah you got to have
cuz funny so my co-host for my radio
show James Andre Jefferson Jr he's like
man you know he goes to a black church
every Sunday and he like Yeah man they
played jelly Roose speech at church bro
yeah I was like what yeah man hey man
God God God going to make a way such a
crazy like it's just so dope to see
somebody like that who's been like a
peer a friend and and just to have just
this whole other like and if you ever
have known jelly you know he's always
been this guy who you're like man if
people just talk to you they love you if
if they gave it a chance so many people
and again congratulations jelly I love
you I love you I love your family man
you and your your wife or bomb I'm happy
for you I look forward to 40 50 more
years of you just doing it dope um I
um my my my thing is man just give folks
a shot that my my thing is I didn't want
to die without you really having met
Michael and and give me a shot I knew
you hadn't listened to me cuz everything
you say you missing in rap I already am
I was already giving you dope you know
and it it I'm glad that you didn't and
you turn death here to me for as long as
you did cuz it gave me an opportunity to
find the discipline through run the
jewels of how to take 2 and 1/2 years to
make Michael it took me 10 years of
being with run of Jews to understand I
am building a community I'm not just
talking to an audience it took me 10
years to understand now seven years
because I started about three years ago
took me seven years to understand now
it's time you know and I take it
seriously and and not seriously to the
fact it ain't fun right or you and your
lady can't get blasted to it and go to
the flame eat some chicken wng see
something drop but I take it seriously
in that I'm trying to give you or know
I've giving you a level of quality that
you deserve as a listener you know hiip
hop is looked at as something that does
not involve High art and culture or if
it does it doesn't involve it from a
working class standpoint you know
somehow in order to be of high standard
you have to be collegate or you have to
wear you know weird [__] with weird
[__] names you know I'm wearing an
ebbit field jacket and I feel stylish as
a [__] cuz this [__]
made in America and it's about football
and this is the good jacket my grandpa
put on when he wasn't working you know
and and that's that's what that's what
I'm a that's what I'm about I take pride
in this [__] I take pride in the fact of
knowing that whether it was Pony or Puma
or Nike we did that we created sneaker
culture Nike doesn't happen without hip
hop in the same capacity it just doesn't
starter starter doesn't happen without
you name you can literally name anything
it doesn't it doesn't happen so l i take
this [__] you know what I'm saying like
I I take it that seriously I love this
[__] dog I love this [__] to my core I
love the [__] with my bones this ain't
some [__] I'm doing on the way to
somewhere else you know you guys have
done such a great job of in a world in
which it feels like the business model
of being a rapper
is uh extremely hard if you're
especially an independent rapper right
like it ain't easy it's not easy because
if you're just looking at what a a
million streams pays you right it it
feels like a almost like a hopeless
climb up a mountain in order to really
make a career or be able to just support
your yourself let alone your family
right um you guys have done such a good
job over the last 10 years of um
monetizing the brand right what are some
things that you're doing with
Michael whether it's V obviously the
tour was successful yeah um you know I
think always tell people like if you're
if you got a fan base and you're not and
you don't have a hard weight obviously
people are going to stream it but you
want them to buy the 12-in vinyl you
want them to buy a CD a tape man I'm not
going to pretend to be no Mastermind I I
follow I follow my brother currency man
shouts out to him SP man he's who's on
the album yeah him yeah him and two
chaines they on my dope boy record
usually your dope boy record you're
hearing we sold the most dope sometimes
dope boys just throw a dope barbecue and
invite all the other dope boys to come
out and you see their cars you get
motivated to do good in school cuz your
mama tell you they did good in school
that's why they got it that's how our
record hits me when I the spaceship
views so I got to figure out shooting
something of that but
spitter um I love the the relax ways
that him like him and and mus move like
cuz it's just he do what's genuinely him
I remember going down there when he had
the car shop you can go get your breaks
and and [__] around and be have a
30-minute combo with sp there you know
crazy imag get your braks done and
you're hanging out C you know what I'm
saying like that's that's the kind of
[__] I'm into so I just leaned into the
[__] that I I love and like my wife and
I built um in the swag shop over the
last 11 years I bought that when I was
recording rap music I sold my 95 Impala
and bought the swag shop off Craigslist
the first swag shop and i' I've been to
that one y I've been to the first one
yeah yep that's on Ros Highway we got
one on edge we got one State Farm Arena
we rolling out two to three next year um
you know I'm like I've had a it took us
five to really kind of figure out what
we were doing I just always wanted to
have a barber shop cool place I got I
have to wait in line but what we
realized doing Co especially when we
closed moms were dming me like don't
close y'all shops y'all shops is one of
the only places that I can bring my boy
I know he's in the company of good men
with Integrity I'm treated with respect
there was just and then they say man we
love when y'all do the little t-shirt
drops and stuff so we were like man we
going to have to be paying R let's just
press up some shirts and what we realize
is man you are a brand operating as a
barber shop yeah I mean I I think I B I
I got a new era yeah so we got we got
more New Era stuff coming we got more
t-shirts and stuff coming we got more
product everything cigarette lighters as
trays cool stuff coming but we're a
barber shop and we've spent some time
figuring out what kind of shampoos I
like I hate to smell girly so it's not
like I'm using my girl stuff I hate the
the I don't want to smell like Old Spice
like my dad you know what I mean so we
developed um I got a shampoo conditioner
thing coming out I got some shaving
cream coming out beer balm I just got
some cool stuff that you can just buy
when you at the shop you get getting a
haircut so I'm excited about that to see
what that's going to do because I know
that as a man I don't like going in the
beauty supply stores as a guy when my
Jordans drop I might I might have no
problem paying $200 for the for the
Jordans but I don't want to pay $150 for
a t-shirt hey what up y'all we got to
stop the interview tell you about our
good Folks at King pom that's right let
me tell you about King pom man it's all
we smoking over here what I love about
King pom turpine infused flavor in each
one of these These are the margarita now
this is kind of the wave I've been on
recently these Margarita ones are
[__] fire no tobacco no nicotine
straight raw organic fresh leaves um and
what's dope is they got the tip you
squeeze the tip you hit one of these
boys and you just get hit with that
flavor man you get hit with that flavor
no matter how big or small the Palm is
you know what I'm saying this is what's
dope too uh King pom if y'all don't know
man they're one of the leading Brands
when it comes to this real like organic
smoke light that's why I like them I
like to smoke clean nothing smokes
cleaner than a King Palm so if you're in
your hood you're in your neighborhood
you're in your [__] City your
area wherever you're at go to your local
liquor store they're going to have King
poms all right so pick them up there you
could also go to 7-Eleven or this is
what I suggest you do right
now come on shout out to the king poms
man go to the website King pom.com if
you go to King pom.com you use the promo
code bootleg
this is what we're doing 50% off
whatever you order they got so much at
King pom.com not only do they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the Gast
trays they got them all the cones
50% off all the smoking accessories all
the leaves you need all the flavors 50%
off King pom.com promo code bootleg also
speaking of [__] you're going to get
some money off of our family our dogs
our our listen I'm going to uh Tampa to
go DJ for these guys holiday party odd
Soxs baby the holidays are here now is
the time to go to oddsocks official.com
and use that promo code bootleg all
right use it right now and guess what
you're going to get 20% off at checkout
now the dope thing about odd Soxs they
got all the crazy licenses they just
locked down Coca-Cola recently yeah look
at those they just locked down Hasbro so
they got Power Rangers transform warmers
all that I mean look they got cheit bro
you know what I'm saying they got
Hershey's chocolate bro they got WWE
they got Breaking Bad they got Top Ramen
they got the drawers they got the socks
they got the slippers they got the Hat
they got the belt whatever you need odd
Sox official.com load up for the
holidays gift odd Sox to your loved ones
whatever they're into there's an odd Sox
for it oddo official.com use the promo
code bootleg when you check out save 20%
off let's get back to the interview
what's your favorite Jay my favorite Jay
um I'm my favorite let me give you my
favorite alltime Nike the 87 Air Max
okay you got Air Maxes on now you got
what
those but yeah so that that's my
favorite Jay's I just whatever I'm
Jordan threes you like the threes I like
the four to me is the most all around
it's the three or four for me the three
is very uncomfortable but it's just such
a I probably like the silhouette of the
for to B yeah four is amazing man no
it's it's and then yeah you know you
guys just dropped your own Nike SBs yeah
we did we did man we did hey what's up
with are you ever going to do a new
season of the Netflix show it was so
good I Trigg one we going to see
something cool got thank you man we got
some I got the chops for this [__] man
so and then you had a show on Facebook
what was yeah that was the roll with
Killer Mike that's C back too so yeah
but the but the trigger warning was the
one the trigger warning was one the fact
you like the the [__] Cola criola and
blood pop yeah that was legendary man we
got more coming man we got more coming
it's it's um if if you haven't seen it
go watch it and just hit me up and let
me know what you think about it it's
still on Netflix still on Netflix do you
feel like um we're turning the corner I
mean obviously the name of the show is
trigger War a lot of people for the last
five or six years get triggered easily
and there's a lot of online outrage
you've been subject to some of that when
you did with the gun thing people were
coming at you crazy but I wonder do you
feel like society's turning a corner
when it comes to like some of the like
more sens like people just have been
like all time sensitive I don't know I
don't care i' I learned my lesson my
grandfather was who he was for a reason
I bet you if if the world go down
tomorrow the power grid shut up I bet
you my family and me eat you got I bet
you we'll be okay is the crib
sustainable do you have like if if the
[__] stops tomorrow you'll be all right
I'm going to be okay that's what I'm
saying in matters of being triggered I
just like to tell people man don't let
that anxiety get to you man just take
care of yourself you know do right by
yourself and do right by other people CU
if you keep worrying about what the
world's going to do you're never going
to take time to live you spend your
waste your time worrying now just you
know in telling whatever your version of
the truth is just remember on the other
side of that truth is somebody else is
thinking or feeling or logic and on the
other side of that may be some
repercussions and whatever those are
they are but man I make sure my kids
watch guard George Carlin I make sure my
kids watch watch Richard Pryor I I make
sure my kids cuz you you need to make
make sure that there's a healthy human
distrust of systems
mhm and I think I think we've gotten rid
of like what you just said is like
however you feel whatever your truth is
the other side that's their truth you
know doesn't make it the truth it
doesn't make it the truth but there's
got to be some dialogue man I smoked I
got on the plane to come out here and I
watched something my gay Uncle watched
30 years ago and I just was too young to
even
understand um to watch it at all I got a
chance to see a lot of stuff cuz my
parents were so young other kids
wouldn't seen but um Paris is burning
such an interesting movie you know it's
about these gay kids in New York and
about these drag balls that they're
throwing so that and and but but what I
learned about poverty and I had a friend
named Kevin man he was an amazingly
brilliant organizer he was a kid whose
parents because he was gay had kicked
him out and he lived in a fostered home
of sorts and I saw him be used and
abused by older men in terms of you
could tell the stories you know I was
hip enough to know if he came in with a
black ey something happen you know what
I mean that kind of [__] but it made me
really have even more empathy and love
for him he's gone now you know God bless
the dead but I saw these kids that were
just from poverty they were just poor
kids so they they they talked about how
how at first with the older guys at that
time they had you know done big feathers
and balls and and things it made them
feel good about themselves it was an
alternative feeling of poverty and then
the kids got into designer you know
there was it was eant lant that kind of
thing and and they they presented
themselves that way but I didn't know
there were all these subcategories of
what was real what could and I just said
wow this really is a group of human
beings that created another reality for
themselves as a as a as an alternative
to pain and Desperation essentially I
participate in that through hip hop
essentially kids who are who are sports
heads participate in that Sports if you
hear somebody ever talk about Jiu-Jitsu
you'll think they're talking about a
religion you understand what I'm saying
for sure so so for me it that helped
expand my understanding in a way that I
cannot go forward not understanding you
know what I mean I can go forward
disagreeing or agreeing or I can't go
forward exactly and now so for me I'm
I'm on a a mission or a journey in life
trying to understand more I always say
that about like the abortion thing like
however however you feel about the
abortion thing I'm I mean obviously I'm
a pro-choice guy to within reason but
like the other side I get if you feel
like it's murder I I can't even say
nothing to you I understand your
perspective and I understand why you're
so passionate about it I might not agree
but you got your stance and I get it
people have to be more like aware of
like other people's perspective cuz you
work with people who you don't agree
with every day you're you're you're
going to stand in line next to somebody
at Subway with somebody you don't agree
with every he them out even if you
disagree and you could disagree I got a
television show called love and respect
we just want an for it um want to
daytime want to Amy for um interview
with Bernice King Dr King's um youngest
daughter Dr daughter I remember see it
but but this show is all about just
having conversations with people I might
agree or disagree with you know and I
and i' I've disagreed with blatantly
liberal people disagree with blatantly
conservative people here and and my
thing is at the end of each talk though
I've I've know I've connected more to
another human being and I think that
should be ultimately that's be what
we're pushing for so even matters of
business if I'm selling a product it's
because it's from a place of my own
Humanity I wanted a barber shop I think
barber shops are cool places to buy my
t-shirts and socks cuz I don't want to
buy it at the [__] gas station so my
barber shop sells a branded heather gray
black and white t that's fire you go get
your white tea at the bar you get your
white tea right there and it's and and
it and it matches your JS it's the same
he great you get what I'm saying you
know I don't I don't want to go in the
beauty supply store with with with with
my cousins with the [__] caps on
their head and my little niece is
running through that [__] so you can
buy your shampoos and soaps right there
I want it so I want to create business
that's natural you know to me I just got
like 30,000 square foot of warehouse
space in Atlanta we're going to be doing
our own you know similar [__] Studio
that's man you know so I just I'm just
trying to leave a legacy of you doing
recording studios or cre just no from
film and film and film and um and audio
um so you're going to be able to do
recording studios you going to be able
to record your podcast the new Hollywood
man yeah I I think shout to Tyler Perry
I I me his pace is CRA he's a man man he
watch his I didn't know I was so heavily
involved but they used me a lot in his
um his Prime movie that just is the
documentary that came I want to watch it
cuz I powerful and inspired he's like
the boss power he's powerful this guy
should have owned BET right now they
[__] that up well something going to
happen you you don't you don't get it
the first time you know no but it's
crazy he should don't be a black person
should don't be hey I agree but we going
to see it's going to happen Byron Allen
byon Allen wanted it too yeah yeah I
think you know I think 50 took a shot at
it I want to see I'm cheering for us all
to win yeah now 50 I was just well I
want we we we had a uh there's a network
that somebody just left recently and I
was like what if 50 came in and ran that
Network and had all his own like 50
needs his own network if you I think
it's gonna happen like he pops Stars off
I think it's gonna happen yeah it's it's
uh it's crazy well listen man um the
album is a piece of art it's thank
beautiful album everyone you go listen
to it it's my album of the year um I
really actually don't even think it's
close I mean that with all due respect
usually I would tell you if I was like
yeah and and technically Metro boomman
came out last year and I love the Metro
boomman album but this year I don't
think it's close shouts out to Metro I
don't think it's close I don't I there's
not another album that has even made me
quite cuz usually I'm like man there's
by the time December hits you're like
damn there's like three or four it's
only one and then the rest and just sit
down and if Y and if y'all think is man
just sit down and listen this one open
hard man you ain't got to like me but
boy it's going to be hard not to love
this album 100% man um hey I wonder are
you are you going back on Rogan anytime
soon I know that's a friendship over the
years yeah Rogan is yeah ran first of
all definitely friendship love him to
death and his whole staff over there
those guys are great have you been to
the comedy Mothership yet yes I I got
went over there stoned the [__] he saw
it it was amazing he he put me up in
these little the seats in the balcony it
was hella dark no one even knew I was in
there was it was it was dope I had a
great time Rogan man I just want to say
I just um just man he um to me man he he
stands on the side of of Truth tellers
you know I don't you don't always people
don't always agree with him he doesn't
always agree with people we don't always
agree with one another but man there's
something to be said for letting people
have platform to just discuss agences
and disagrees so age you know I value
value it for that reason you know value
him as a human for that reason and he
taught me the beauty of eating elk meat
and peppers cuz godamn that motherfu
seen those posts I haven't ever had have
you had you have elk meat have it it's
good it's a venison of sorts you know
what I mean so so sweet deer me you
remember we eat de like deer and hog you
know that's what you I feel so terrible
me me and that Mexican OT just killed
Hogs and left them yeah I mean like you
should have I mean I'm just you know I
guess you ain't got to eat every but if
you going you should eat a hog you kid
we we had to loaded them into the
helicopter yeah yeah but you sometimes
there trucks too that are out there they
right so I would think they don't they
don't eat any of the Hogs no they just
where my grandpa was from man they um
has a hog farm down there so they they
you know Crow hog they and and they
slaughter the hog there and they'd
already have dug a pit into the ground
so my grandmother they cook the Hogs
above ground like tus where my grandpa
was from they cook their hogs in the
ground totally different type of flavor
I bet crazy oh man so [__] good
that's where I said the same thing I'm
like guys can we like can we like take
something from this hog so don't feel as
bad they're like no coyotes will eat
them somebody's going to eat it damn
like we just there's too many of them
there's millions of them that's when you
know Texas got all the money that's when
you know you're Rich As [__] you just go
man I'm I'm soow stressed I'm going to
kill some [__] Hogs that's really
it yeah anyway I appreciate you pulling
up Mike love and respect um first of all
congrats on the nominee and I listen
February I think is when the Grammys are
yeah February 4 I believe so I want to
party with us man so hey man y'all send
me a lot of good energy man and um you
know the people on the gramming
Committees man I just want to I just
want to say I want to employ that you
get an album of listen with an open
heart you know yeah it's it's no better
representation of rapping this 50 of a
year than this album I don't I know how
the Grammys work I just know that you
know they've gotten some stuff right and
they've gotten some stuff wrong they got
it right that they nominated you and
let's hope they get it right that let's
bring it out the way you got to bring
one of them three home yeah yeah I want
you know the one I want rrap album of
the year it covers everything you know
100% man there it is man Killer Mike my
guy appreciate you brother love and
respect yes sir yes sir all right man of
course we want to shout out to our
family at harden baby Harden Las Vegas
celebrating their seventh birthday this
month so happy birthday to harden uh
want to give a shout out to the whole
family over there there when you're in
Las Vegas you got to pull up the Hardy
and tell them that the bootleg head
podcast sends you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
Under One Roof you walk in and it's just
a Vibe beautiful Bud tenders amazing
smoke just the illst merch you know what
I'm saying and it's right in Las Vegas
right in Sin City so you land in Vegas
you about to go gamble with your boys
you get in that cab you say take me to
harden they're going to know exactly
where to take you all right shout out to
harden go follow him Hardin Vegas or go
to the website Hardin vegas.com